cet été les yvelines seront bien
représentés pendant ces jeux olympiques
de tokyo le contingent évinois devrait
être composée d'une dizaine de sportifs
parmi eux trois triathlètes du club de
poissy seront de la partie dorian coninx
cassante beaugrand et léonie périodes
cette dernière connaîtra ses premiers jo
c'est un honneur de représenter kouassi
parce qu'on ait fait pas je les côtoie
de cuir depuis je pense 2010 par là donc
c'est vraiment ma c'était le but et on a
réussi en golf antoine ros nord du golfe
de la boulie à versailles représentera
la france sur cette compétition après
une année 2010 21 de haut niveau une
victoire au qatar masters
à 28 ans le sportif espère remporter une
médaille en aviron la rameuse claire
beauvais de l'association sportive
mantaise fait partie des favoris dans
son sport pour un podium cet été un
podium
franchement c'est un beau rêve
on a les armes pour se battre dans la
catégorie pour faire des belles choses
donc c'est un beau rêve mais un petit
peu réaliste quand même en cyclisme sur
piste ils seront plusieurs à partir au
japon la fédération française a décidé
de miser sur la jeunesse avec 4 pépite
mathilde de gros 21 ans sébastien vie
j'ai 24 ans rennes et la halle 22 ans et
florian grings bovins en licencier au vc
skyteam vous sert le réel objectif
une carrière sportive de haut niveau qui
est la médaille aux jeux olympiques donc
très content mais il ya encore beaucoup
de travail et pourra chercher la plus
belle des médailles en bmx cinq sportifs
qui s'entraînent sur le stadium à côté
du vélodrome nationale vont s'envoler
pour les jeux on retrouve dans la
sélection manon valentino axel etienne
silva andré le triple champion du monde
joris daudet ou encore romain mahieu je
pense que pour chaque sportif de haut
niveau participe aux jeux olympiques
c'est c'est le plus gros objectif d'une
carrière donc super content ça va juste
la première étape
maintenant on va y aller
pour une médaille ce qui est le rêver et
pourquoi on travaille tous les jours
en judo à 34 ans guillaume chaîne
participera à ses premiers jeux
olympiques après avoir été remplaçant en
2016 à rio
judoka espère faire briller son club de
sartrouville au niveau international
dans la catégorie des moins de 73 kg
l'objectif comme chacun des athlètes qui
se présente aux jeux olympiques
j'espère pour eux c'est d'aller
décrocher l'or maintenant moi c'est mes
premiers jeux olympiques donc c'est déjà
une petite victoire en soit maintenant
j'y vais pas pour figurer non plus en
boxe maiva hamadouche a réussi à se
qualifier pour les jeux olympiques la
sportive du boxing club saint quentin en
yvelines sera dans la catégorie des
moins de 60 kg une grande première pour
cette boxeuse passé professionnel en
2013 c'était surtout quand on est un
boxeur professionnel jamais vraiment
laissé des jeux olympique de côté parce
que savoir quand on est sportif
quand on est boursière professionnels on
n'a pas le droit de se présenter aux
jeux olympiques ça s'est ouvert pour les
en gros à rio la sévère pour les femmes
également la porte aux kyo un très chaud
ces jo sur légion tout simplement
donc en fait pour moi c'est une chance
inestimable
enfin en bas le versailles et valentin
porte devrait faire partie de l'équipe
de france à tokyo champion du monde avec
les experts en 2015 et 2017
l'arrière droit espère remporter cette
fois ci un titre olympique avec la
sélection tricolore série noire vont-ils
tous performer à tokyo réponse à partir
du 23 juillet